somehow they've left me outside of the
studio how did that happen we are out
here of course for founders day here at
channel 8 an annual event we've done for
the last several years helping local
nonprofits and today it is serving our
kids and joining us here at noon greg
hogan who is a board member worth
serving our kids greg thank you for
joining us thank you for having me let's
talk about what serving our kids does
here in the valley and and really the
need right now
if i may first i'd like to start out by
thanking klas
for hosting this event for us uh it's uh
so important because uh our organization
doesn't get any state or federal funds
uh so we're totally dependent upon local
organizations to help us out and we
really appreciate this and we're hoping
that other organizations who may see me
will look us up on serving our kids.org
and reach out to us we'd really love to
hear from you well so far we've already
had a lot of donations here behind me
we've got bottled water a lot of bottled
water i see the aviators behind us too i
might catch up with you in a second
buddy
all sorts of food is here as well
there's a big need in the community
right now absolutely and serving our
kids we're a grassroots organization
all volunteers and
what we do is we feed
through clark county school systems
about 4 500
kids a year
and
135 schools
and that goes on all year long and
sometimes during the summer we can also
give out
food bags to children
and
we feel the need is about 10 000
children out there
so we're trying to grow our operation to
meet that need of ten thousand children
so again we need your help and we'd
really appreciate it if you'd reach out
to us well greg thank you very much we
appreciate your time it's very nice to
meet you sir let's quickly take a look
around here mark you can see what we've
got here uh capri sun we've got
applesauce lots and lots of bottled
water we got the aviator here it's good
to see you sir uh we need to put you to
work though look at all this bottled
water can we get some stuff we got all
those mussels let's get some stuff going
here what do you say all right let's do
it oh here's some food right here
oh this is from the aviator fantastic we
appreciate it thank you very much las
vegas aviators for that your work is
great we love baseball too uh we have
more eight news now at noon coming up in
just a few moments and of course again
founders day until six o'clock make
donations just like this help some kids
in our valley get the food they really
need more eight news now is coming up
right after this stay tuned